اهلا بكم في هذه التغطيه
المتواصله لذكرى العشرين لانطلاق العربيه
منذ بدايات العربيه كان قدرها تغطيه موسعه
في مختلف بلدان العالم لاحداث لم ولن تنسى
جهود كبيره بذلها مراسلون ولا يزالون
لتعرفوا اكثر نستذكر معكم هنا بعض
التغطيات على قناه العربيه لاحداث بارزه
في عالمنا العربي قبل نحو 20 عاما
[موسيقى]
وردنا منذ قليل فقد افادت وكاله رايترز
للانباء ان انفجارا قويا هزا اليوم منطقه
شاطئ بيروت
تردنا المعلومات عن مقتل اربعه اشخاص على
الاقل واصابه العشرات
[موسيقى]
فليحيى
المرافق الشخصي للرئيس الوزراء السابق
رفيق الحريري
انباء عن اصابه خطيره لرئيس الوزراء
السابق رفيق الحريري
مشاهدينا الكرام وردنا قبل قليل ان رئيس
الوزراء اللبنانيه السابق رفيق الحريري قد
قضى في هذا الانفجار
[موسيقى]
وتصوريه تنهي تواجدا عسكريا واستخباراتيا
استمر نحو ثلاثه عقود في لبنان ودمشق تبلغ
مجلس الامن بتنفيذها الكامل للقرار 1559
اكد مدير التوجيه في الجيش اللبناني ان اي
جندي او عنصر امني سوري لن يبقى في لبنان
بعد انتهاء حفل الوداع الرسمي للقوات
السوريه
[موسيقى]
دوريه اليوم تكمل انسحاب قواتها العسكريه
والامنيه
اكد مصدر في الجيش الاسرائيلي ان عشرات من
صواريخ الكاتيوشا وقذائف الهون سقطت صباح
اليوم على منطقه الجليل الاعلى شمال
اسرائيل كيف تنقل لنا الاجواء بعد العمليه
في سهل مرجعيون يعني ما قبل الظهر كان
الاسرائيليون ايضا اطلقوا اكثر من 30
قذيفه باتجاه بعض المواقع
[موسيقى]
لا يمكن ان ارجعيون هي النقطه الاهم
والمدينه الاهم التي يعني اولى المدن التي
دخلها الجيش الاسرائيلي
قال رئيس الوزراء اللبناني فؤاد السنيوره
ان معركه نهر البارد هي معركه اللبنانيين
والفلسطينيين ضد مجموعه من الارهابيين
[موسيقى]
ارتفع عدد الجنود اللبنانيين الذين قتلوا
في الاشتباكات الى 23 جنديا فيما ارتفعت
حصيله قتل جماعه فتح الاسلام الى 17 احدهم
فجر نفسه
[موسيقى]